es gibt krasse maßnahmen fürs
energiesparen und das auf kosten der
kinder wie in dieser grundschule in
hagen in nordrhein-westfalen dort
bleiben nämlich die heizungen in schulen
und in turnhallen kalt die stadt
schaltet die heizungen einfach ab auch
das duschwasser bleibt kalt ja auch nach
den sommerferien bis ende september soll
es einfach kalt dort bleiben damit will
man den gasverbrauch senken und unsere
reporterin lisa und verfährt ist jetzt
in hilden und hat für uns einmal
nachgefragt lisa hallo bei den
verantwortlichen was einem video gesagt
die verantwortlichen haben gesagt und
das ist nun mal die stadt bilden dass
wir diese maßnahmen eingeleitet haben um
den energieverbrauch zu sprechen dazu zu
senken wie möchten sagt der baudezernent
peter stahlträger die bevölkerung dazu
anstiften ein zeichen setzen den
gasverbrauch zu senken und da der
dringende appell damit die gasspeicher
und winter hin voll bleiben das problem
ist natürlich wie sieht es nach dezember
aus dass nördlichsten stadt bislang
ungewiss
plant die stadt denn da noch weitere
maßnahmen und vor allen dingen auch wer
ist denn jetzt alles betroffen also wie
viele schüler wie viele lehrer müssen
dort jetzt ja kalt duschen ja an
insgesamt neun schulen hier an neuen
städtischen schulen in hilden und das
betrifft sowohl die grundschulen als
auch die sekundarschulen spricht
gymnasium gesamtschulen müssen dann bis
mindestens ende september kalt kalt
duschen nach dem sportunterricht und
auch die vereine müssen dann in dem
moment wenn sie danach der nach dem
schrott
verschwitzt sind und duschen möchten
können sie es nicht mehr tun war die
müssen kalt duschen und das besonders
natürlich auch die client für die
grundschüler die ja ihren
sportunterricht nachgehen wollen nicht
nicht schön und es gibt natürlich auch
wenn es jetzt
am 9 august an hier in nrw sommerferien
und dann sind es noch knapp zwei monate
wo die heizung an den grundschulen aus
bleiben wo das warmwasser aus bleibt
ausgeschlossen davon sind wie
ganztagsbetreuung das betrifft aber nur
eine städtische grundschule und auch die
das rathaus hat mich ein zeichen setzen
wollen dadurch dass sie sagen bei uns
bleibt das waren was er auch zumal aus
thema ja immerhin einmal das wieviel
glaubt man denn dadurch einsparen zu
können im september muss man sagen da
kann es durchaus mal kalte tage geben
und da wäre es ganz schön wenn man im
klassenzimmer so ein bisschen die
heizung anstellen könnte also das muss
schon was bringt mit was rechnet man
denn da also allein heute wir haben ja
im juli und ich könnte sagen weil ich
gerade im stress ist jetzt auch nicht
sonderlich warm selbst im august und im
september wie du gerade was das kalte
tage werden die stadt rechnet mit
einsparungen finnland fehlen von einigen
10.000 euro sagte die stadtsprecherin
heute aber darum ging erst gar nicht die
stadt möchte damit einfach ein zeichen
selbst sagten sie und sagen sie sind
gerade in dieses ukraine hat das
verursacht wir möchten einsparungen
treffen und deshalb haben sie sich
gesetzt bis ende september dann
mindestens die heizung aus zulassung
auch das war im wasser und das betrifft
natürlich nicht nur die schüler nicht
nur die lehrer sondern auch du sport bei
einer turnhalle minuten wieder normal zu
gehör ich bin zu dem städtischen schulen
vielen dank lisa und verwertete eine
recherche dort in hilden in
nordrhein-westfalen und jetzt schauen
wir mal ob sich da noch mehrere schulen
anschließen und da eben den gashahn
zudrehen danke dir